لاول مره منذ حرب الجواسيس بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق والولايات المتحده اثناء
الحرب البارده تشتعل حرب اخرى صامته
ميدانها الفضاء سبراني بين موسكو ووشن
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اشارت الى انشاء
واشنطن قوه المهمه
2012 كجزء من القياده السبرانيه الامريكيه
وهي المنظمه العسكريه في الولايات المتحده
القوه بدورها تدعم الدفاع الرقمي
الاوكراني عبر مشاورات يوميه ما ساعد في
الكشف عن الالاف من الاشارات التحذيريه
لشبكات الكمبيوتر الاوكرانيه التي يحتمل
ان تكون معارضه للخطر بحسب الصحيفه وحتى
الان يبدو الامر انه قد تم رد روسي عن
توجيه هجمه سوبرانيه مباشره ضد الولايات
المتحده او حلف الناتو هذا ما يقوله قائد
القوه السبرانيه الامريكيه الذي يتحسب
منها هجمه تستهدف الولايات المتحده ربما
ينفذها ناشطون سبرانيون روس يفلتون من
سلطه الكرملين الذي لم يدرس بعد قرار
مهاجمه الناتو وفقا لنيويورك تايمز
المخاوف الامريكي دفعت واشنطن الى تخصيص
2000 شخص من عناصر القوات المسلحه للعمل
ضمن القوه السبرانيه التي وزعت ايضا
ثمانيه وثلاثين فريقا في 21 دوله للمساعده
على تعزيز الشبكات الحاسوبيه من استهداف
انظمه معلوماتها وبيانات المؤسسات
الحكوميه لمسح او تعطيل او تدمير خدمتها
في حرب تحققوا مصالح بلدانها من غير
الحاجه لمعدات ثقيله وبتكلفه اقل من
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه حنان المصري
العربي